اللي كانوا بيمثلوا ترامب من بدايه
الاتهامات الى اليوم اما القاضي لتحول
لنجم بسبب هذه القضيه او اللي مثل امامه
ترامب فهو القاضي اخوان مرجان القاضي
المحكمه العليا في نيويورك بالانابه التي
تم وصفه بانه محنك وصارم وعادل في نفس
الوقت وفي وهو نفسه حكم سابقا بالسجن
المدير المالي لمؤسسه ترامب وتراس كمان
محاكمه الاحتلال الضريبي للمؤسسه واشرف
على قضيه الاحتيال الجنائي لمستشار ترامب
السابق ستيف بانون ويمكن عشان كذا قال
ترامب انه هذا القاضي بيكرهه نجم اخر من
نجوم القضيه هو المدعي العام اللي طلع
بمؤتمر صحفي من اقل من ساعه وقال وجهنا 34
اتهاما لترامب لمحاوله اخفاء جرائم اخرى
وقال انه ما في دوافع سياسيه حول قضيه
ترامب وانه نفذ تحقيق الشامل بشانها وقال
كمان انه تبع سلوك اجرامي خطير وانتهك
قوانين تمويل الحملات الانتخابيه ودفع
اموال رشاوي عبر شركات وهميه وقدم تصريحات
زائفه لتغطيه جرائم مرتبطه بانتخابات 2016
ودفع اموال لتزوير سجلاته التاريخ او
التجاريه طيب قبل المدعي العام محامين
ترامب كانوا وبعد مغادرتهم مبنى المحكمه
اتكلموا مع الاعلام وقالوا ان اتهاموا
كلهم الرئيس السابق يؤكد ان سياده القانون
ماتت في هذه البلاد وانه ما في اي مؤشرات
على ارتكاب الرئيس السابق لاي جريمه
فيدراليه وقالوا كمان انه اتهامه امر محبط
وحزين
وحقيقه الاسئله الان كثيره جدا ايش اللي
راح يصير هل راح يسجن ترامب واذا انسجن رح
يترجح من السجن للرئاسه وهل في حال اذا
انتم راح يتم منعه من الترشح للرئاسه
اسئله كثيره والكل بيبحث عن اجابات لانه
في النهايه ترامب اول رئيس امريكي بيتم
توجيه تهم جنائيه له طيب احنا حينضم الينا
من عمان المحامي المزاول في نيويورك محمد
تيسير النعيمي اهلا فيك معانا وخلينا
نبتدي اول شيء من التهم الموجه نحن بنتكلم
عن 34 تهمه بس يعني ما احنا عارفين ايش
الفرق بانه هي جنائيه بس برجعوا بعدين
قالوا انه لا هي جنح وتهم بسيطه اذا تقدر
تشرح لنا ايش الفرق قالوا ايه حتى وصفوها
اهلا
ويس هو رمضان كريم نعم يعني اسند اليوم
لرئيس الولايات المتحده الامريكيه السابق
دونالد ترامب 34 تهمه جنائيه وليست جنحه
تتعلق بتقديم معلومات غير صحيحه
لبيانات الماليه المتعلقه
مؤسسه ترامب السبب الرئيسي ليش هذه ما تم
اسنادها كجنحه وتم اسنادها كجنايه لانه
ينص القانون في حال كان الفعل المرتكب
متبوع بينيه جرميه متعلقه باخفاء واقعه
جرميه اخرى او متعلقه بجريمه جرميه اخرى
يتم رفع هذه التهمه الى درجه الجنايه وهذا
ما تم ما تم ما تم اليوم في المحكمه يعني
ارتفع الموضوع الى جنايه لانه شايفين انه
في جرم كان
يعني الهدف كان
جرم معين او خلينا نقول تحقيق ما تم تقديم
هاي المعلومات المغلوطه وفقط ولكن هذه
المعلومات المغلوطه تتعلق بواقعه اخرى قد
تكون غير قانونيه او متعلقه بفعل جرمي
فلما يكون عندي
الحالتين هدول مع بعض يتم رفع هذه التورمه
التهمه الى جنايه وهذا ما يزعموه الادعاء
العام في لائحه الاتهام خليني بس بدي امشي
معك شويه في تفاصيل اللي صار داخل المحكمه
بس عشان نفهم طبعا كان في موضوع انه هو
توجيه التهم كان في قصه انه اخذوا بصمات
وكان في قصه انه يحطوا له كلبشات او ما
يحطوا له كلبشات هذا لم يحدث ما حطوا له
كلبشات كان في قصه المج شوط هم قالوا ما
حياخدوها طالب فيها ترامب ثم هم رفضوا انه
ياخذوا المقشط هذه التفاصيل انه تصير او
ما تصير تلبش او ما يتكلبش هذه اجباريه
ولا بالاتفاق بتصير
بالمجمل الاجباريه ويمكن ان تصير في
حالتين اما تصير في المركز الامني او ممكن
تصير في حال ادخال المتهم عليه الى
المشتكى عليه الى المحكمه في العاده كل ما
زادت حده كل ما زادت درجه التهمه المسنده
تكون الاجراءات مقيده اكثر فيكون المشتكى
عليه بكون مكلبش لما يفوت لازم اخذ صورته
التعريفيه ولازم اخذ ولازم اخذ بصماته
الهدف من الصوره التعريفيه هي للتعرف على
المشتكي عليه فاحد محامين ترامب اثار نقطه
امام القاضي ورقيا لما قدم هذا الطلب انه
ترامب من اكثر الاشخاص المعروفين في هذا
العالم فما في حاجه اصلا لهذه الصوره
التعريفيه ولكن هذا اجراء روتيني بيدخل
الشخص المحكمه يتم ايداعه الى مكتب هذا
المكتب ياخذ بصماته ياخذ صوره المقشط بكون
مكتوب عليها رقم القضيه التحقيقيه ورقم
القضيه اللي بلشت الان
ثم طيب خليني كمان بدي اتكلم معاك على
موضوع الكفاله يعني هو ترامب غادر مقر
المحكمه الجنائيه من دون ان تفرض عليه اي
شروط او مراقبه قضائيه بس هل عاده بيكون
المفروض يكون في كفاله هل بيكون فيه منع
من السفر مثلا في هذه الحاله ولا زي ما
قلت هو شخصيه يعني مشهوره واعتباريه يعني
يا سيدتي هذا هو الاصل ان يتم اطلاق سراح
المشتكي عليه بدون كفاله الا اذا كان
هنالك ظروف او اشي
تتولد ضد القاضي انه ممكن هذا الشخص ما
يمثل في المحاكمه الثانيه او ممكن انه
يهرب خارج البلاد وكل ما زادت حده التهمه
كل ما كانت الكفاله ستكون مشروطه القاضي
ثلاث ثلاث خيارات امامه اطلاق فراحوا بدون
كفاله ما حدث اليوم اطلاق سراح المتهم
عليه مع كفاله او ايداع المتهم عليه الى
السجن هذه في حال العقوبات التي تمتد الى
القاتل والعقبات
القويه ايوه موضوع السفر ولكن كونه ولكن
كونه ترامب هذه اول جنايه يتم
اسنادها اليه وما عنده اسبقيات جرميه
كثيره القاضي انه اطلاق سراحه بدون بدون
كفاله موضوع السفر نفس المعايير والمحددات
بتطبق على السفر في حال كان عند القاضي
انه ممكن المشتكى عليه انه يسافر او ممكن
انه يفر من هذه البلد هيحط عليه منع سفر
انا تحليلي لربما سيكون هنالك منع سفر
ولكن هذا سيعتمد على كيف بتتطور القضيه
يعني هاي من القرارات المستعجله قد يمكن
انه القاضي يصدرها في بدايه المحكمه ويمكن
ان تصدر في وقت لاحق كيف تطور القضيه ممكن
ينزل قرارات مستعجله اخرى طيب خليني اقول
لك بس سريعا طلب
رئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب تغيير
مكان
المحاكمه لانه شايف انه مكان المحاكمه
الحالي غير محايد بالنسبه له هل تتوقع
ممكن يصير هذا الشيء او يلبى طلبه
لا اتوقع لانه هنالك محددات قانونيه للطعن
في ولايه المحكمه المكانيه زي ما هم
بطعنوا على الفانيو ولكن هو ثابت الولايه
على ترامب نفسه والولايه على الفعل الجرمي
ثابته الى
والمحكمه اللي في منهات اللي هي المحكمه
المختصه بمثل هذه البيانات التجاريه
الادعاء اللي قدموه محاميه ترامبو ترامب
نفسه انه هاي المحكمه الليبراليه ومتحيزه
للديمقراطيين وكامل الكادر فيها يميل
للديمقراطيين لا اتوقع ان يرتقي الى يرتقي
الى سبب قانوني يمكن ان ينقل منه المحكمه
الى موقع اخر وهما
طالبوا ان تنت المحكمه الى مقاطعه وهي احد
خمس مقاطعات ولايه نيويورك طيب
خلينا نتكلم عن الاحتمالات اللي ممكن تصير
هل ممكن ان يسجن
يعني في سابقه اليوم ولكن مو ملاقيين
عليها معلومات كفايه وهي انه غير الجنايات
التي تم اسنادهم الى ترامب تم اسناد طبعا
جنايه التامر وهذه لانها متعلقه بالجنايه
بولايه نيويورك يمكن ان تكون مده الحبس
اكثر من الجنايه نفسها
كون انه ترامب الان على الجنايات الاربعه
وثلاثين في حال ادانته بال 34 اتوقع نعم
سيكون مصيره هو هو سجن وفي حال اذانته
بالتامر فيكون مصيره
السجن ولكن ذلك يعتمد على هل سيتمكن ادعاء
العام من اثبات هذه التهم وهل سيتمكن
تامر هي اكبر تهمه بواجهها
يعني هي طبعا اكبر من هاي اكبر من جنايه
الادلاء بمعلومات غير دقيقه
فهمت التامر وهي تهمه التامر استنبطوها من
واقع القصص الثلاثه اللي صرتيها بمقدمتك
الدفعه 150 الف لاحد السيدات
اللي هم بيقدموها طيب الان افتراضا القضيه
مثلا ممكن مشهد سنوات او ممكن مشهد شهور
طويله واحنا داخلين على انتخابات مقبله هل
ممكن ان يترشح وسط هذه القضيه وهي دايره
هل ممكن يترشح اذا كان في السجن
اذا كان في السجن طبعا لا يمكن ان يترشح
لانه يمارس حقوق المدنيه منها حق الترشح
لرئاسه الجمهوريه بعد خروج من السجن ولكن
في حال ادانته واستبدال هذه الادانه
بغرامه او او عدم ادانته او عدم
حبسه فقط الاكتفاء بالغرامه يمكن الترشح
يعني من الغريب انه القانون الامريكي
والدستور الامريكي ما في عنده اي محددات
على حق الترشح كرئيس للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هناك شرطين لازم يتم المترشح
عمر 35 او عمر خمس او المترشحه عمر 35 سنه
ولازم ان يكون مولود في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه او اي في منطقه تحت سيطرتها اذا
قارناها بحق التصويت
سنجد انه هناك محددات اكثر على حق التصويت
ففي بعض الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تفقد
حقق للتصويت في حال ادانتك بجنايه اذا
لاحظنا ب 2016 حاكم ولايه تكساس السابق
كان احد المنافسين
بجنايه ساعه استعمال السلطه في كثير
محاميين وقانونيين جالسين انه بالقضيه
بيقولوا انه هذه القضيه مركبه ما لها اساس
تجميع تهم وما الى ذلك هل بتتفق مع هذا
بعد اطلاعك على تفاصيل القضيه ولا لا
بتعتقد ان لا قضيه جديه وهم عندهم يعني
مكبلينها
يا ستي في اكثر من تهم بالتهم المتعلقه
بالتامر وانه هو هدد نزاهه الانتخابات
الامريكيه اتوقع هاي يعني هاي التهم تفتق
الى سند القانوني ولكن تهم انه هو ادرج
معلومات خاطئه اتوقع انها هي صحيحه
ويعني وثابته وثابته قانونيه ولكن لربما
هناك دوافع سياسيه بتحريكها لانه اذا نيجي
نراجع كامل السجلات التجاريه اللي خاضها
على ولايه محاكم نيويورك حنلاقي هنلاقي
مثل هاي المخالفات بشكل يومي
شكرا لك يعني
استفدنا كثير من المعلومات اللي اعطتنا
اياها اليوم كان معنا من عمان المحامي
المزاول في نيويورك محمد تيسير النعيمي
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]